[Applause]
we did it we're here welcome to the show
the news desk is looking a little
different because we've touched down in
Diva Las Vegas yes we
did uh we are with our CBS Sports family
for Super Bowl 58 we'll be making
ourselves at home in front of the iconic
Bellagio on the Strip for the next 2
days and I'm not doing it alone my
teammate Rossy Ross Matthew is here
joining us is WF radio and CBS Sports
Network host Boomer and
Gio Bo we are so excited thank you thank
you Boer and Gio let's kick things off
by tackling the biggest headline of them
all the Kansas City Chiefs and San
Francisco 49ers will they play this
Sunday now Boomer before you hit the
airwaves you were an All-Star
quarterback for the Bengals in the 1989
Super Bowl
what are you feeling about this game
well my feelings really are two great
quarterbacks but two different types of
quarterbacks we have one who's on the
trajectory to become the greatest
quarterback everri mahes Patrick Mahomes
and then there's Brock pie we're little
get out of Arizona want the Iowa State
last pick in the draft he has been great
his first two years and he's the other
quarterback in the Super Bowl much like
I was and I can tell you I interviewed
him for our Super Bowl today show coming
up on Super Bowl Sunday he a great kid
he is easy to root for so like I'm kind
of conflicted like I want him to win
because it's a great story but it is
Patrick Mahomes and they are living a
dynasty right now I got to ask you
somebody who's played in this game in
that position what advice would you give
to either one of those quarterbacks well
this man here Patrick Mahomes does not
need any advice from me I can tell you
that but I did tell Brock pie enjoy it
he goes how many Super Bowls did you go
to I said one in 14 years it's hard to
make it here and I also want want to ask
you about you know you played for the
Bengals how many years was it 10 years
10 years what's a team that is also
someone that you love and root for I
would say the bills and Josh Allen uhuh
I like Justin Herbert out the Chargers y
so I'm more about players than teams
interesting and coaches I root for
coaches and players like so I feel
Jackson also like is oh God did I just
screw up his name Lamar Jackson Lamar
Jackson yes of course I did because I
was think American Idol no I know we're
all distracted by Taylor Swift let's
face it yeah are you excited about the
Taylor Swift of it all Gio what do you
think it it's gotten to a point now
where it's it's it's too much for the
football fan and in in the beginning it
was cute it was fine and now it's just
she gets shown so much that I feel like
the football fan maybe turns on her a
little bit but this is huge for CBS it's
going to be probably the most watched
Super Bowl ever because she's there I
think to have a love story at the center
of a Super Bowl though is pretty pretty
great yeah we're into it pretty great
all right well let's dive into some
trending story um dads around the
country are getting ready for a Swifty
Super Bowl case in point The Washington
Post reports that dads and daughters are
bonding over football thanks to Taylor
Swift neelon data reports that one of
Swift's first NFL appearances the
ratings among females 12 12 to 17
increased
53% over average um for Sunday night
games one dad said in the article there
isn't a better feeling not just because
she's interested in football but because
she wants to spend time with me about
his own daughter um dad's thoughts okay
so my daughter is 30 and my daughter and
I are texting back and forth over this
whole thing cuz she is a Swifty I'm a
Swifty too now she's an athlete and she
married a professional hockey player and
she loves football because her dad was a
professional football player so she
knows the sport already but the the
whole drama aspect of this that Taylor
is bringing to the sport is real cuz my
30-year-old Swifty daughter is texting
me constantly what are you going to show
her what does she look like today what
is she wearing and I'm like I don't know
I have no idea yeah you know I actually
think this is sort of beautiful the
reason I'm such a big football fan and
Drew we talk about all the time people
are sort of shocked like Ross you're a
football fan is because it was the only
way I could really communicate with my
dad and my brother growing up it was
like the thing that we had in common so
it's just another example of how
football is the common denominator
there's a reason why tens and tens and
tens of millions of people watch the
games every week and the Super Bowl more
than any of them and I think the more
eyes that are brought to the game the
better so if Taylor Swift is doing that
bring it on thank you Taylor now he has
two daughters six and two six and now
they still think I'm a hero and and what
I love about this story is that the
teenage girls who maybe sometimes you
know they they don't get in fights with
Mom and Dad have now the the Taylor
Swift football thing to to have that
Bond listen if Taylor Swift can bring us
together that's kind of what she's best
at seems so I love it all right well
next up my San Antonio reports on two
best friends from Texas whose quest to
find boyfriends by the Super Bowl has
gone viral on Tik Tok I want you boys I
want your take on this so this pair of
best friends began their boyfriend's by
Super Bowl Series in which they visited
a new sports bar every single week to
watch an NFL game and found that it
works better than dating apps um they
went on several dates they're still
looking for their perfect touchdown but
they say they ultimately hope that this
experience empowers other women not to
be so afraid to put themselves out there
I have to know just when you were single
okay if you're at the game looking to
have a a brew ski and watch what if like
a single girl came up to you and tried
to hit on you would you be like oh let
me ignore the game or would you be like
I'm trying to watch the game well I
think the answer that every man wants in
that situation is to be able to talk
about the game together with that girl
this is why I think it's a brilliant
idea yes all right I mean if she
football fans they are football fans yes
and they think well it's it's a good
place to find a guy I mean that's the
key to the anything to get off the apps
you know what I mean
yes yes yes all right so let me just say
this for one second yes Boomer Devil's
Advocate have you ever looked in a
sports bar and seen what's in there
really take a really good
look am I right or am I wrong yeah no
you're right but I mean there's a
difference between the the New York City
young person sports bar than like the
portly villager where I go and Sao like
that's a different situation you don't
want anybody but I like all these hot
takes we have to cut to a quick
commercial we'll be right back for more
news right here in abely Las
Vegas wo